لم يتوقف رد الفعل الروسي على تزويد الغرب
الاسلحه لكيف سياسيا بل عسكريا ايضا حيث
اعلنت انها بدات تدريبات على استخدام
الصواريخ الاسرع من الصوت وذلك في مناطق
الجزء الغربي من المحيط الاطلسي الدفاع
الروسيه قالت ان الفرقه ادميرال جوش كووف
قامت بمحاكاه حاسوبيه لصواريخ زرقاء التي
تتجاوز سرعه الصوت قدرات هذا الصاروخ
فائقه حيث بامكانه التحليق لمسافه تصل الى
احد 10,000 كيلو متر في الساعه ما يعني
انه سيحتاج فقط الى 20 ثانيه فقط للوصول
الى هدف هذا الصاروخ عرف لاول مره في
العام 2017
ووصف بانه لا يقهر واا لا يمكن ايقافه
بواسطه الدفاعات الجويه الغربيه هذا
الصاروخ الحديث ذو القدرات النوويه طوله
يتراوح بين ثمانيه العشره امتار يمكن
اطلاق جوا وبرا وبحرا واا لن اكثر دقه
فلكي تحمي السفن الحربيه الامريكيه نفسها
من هذا الصاروخ القاتل يجب عليها ان ترصده
خلال 20 ثانيه فقط والا ستكون هدفا له
حاله تصاعدت المواجهات المباشره بين
البلدين